coffee on a Tuesday block 13 oh hey
little spider you're trying to scare me
cuz it's a 13th blood yeah that's right
I said it raising awareness is for
pussies let me explain you can see very
clearly on this diagram that I just made
that there are three different types of
rays you can raise awareness you can
raise understanding or you can raise one
of those three clearly one stands out as
being for pussies so to all you fund
hipsters out there who grew your
mustache is for Movember to raise some
awareness for prostate cancer I say yes
it is better than doing nothing but you
are nonetheless still pussies to prove
it to you I'm here at the Comerica Bank
Tower in downtown Los Angeles and I'm
about to walk up 50 flights of steps to
raise awareness for cystic fibrosis look
at all these pussies I'm gonna do one
better not only am I going to climb 50
flights of stairs but I'm gonna raise
some understanding in the process so
every 10 flights I'm gonna explain a
little bit more to you about what cystic
fibrosis is okay
here we go
yeah cystic fibrosis is an encouraging
chronic disease that affects the lungs
and the digestive suspected gene and
it's protein product cause the body to
produce unusually thick and sticky mucus
that clots the lungs that leads to life
threatening lung infections that
obstructs the pancreas which makes
enzymes that help the body break down
food and absorb that's about one 100,000
so maybe you know someone who has it
maybe you jump I do he's 22 years old
the median life expectancy of the
sufferer cystic fibrosis is late 3050
years ago it was about six months
Musselburgh empowering the sufferers of
cystic fibrosis have a mutation on their
seventh chromosome on a gene called the
cystic fibrosis transmembrane
conductance regulator or CF t CF gr
causes thick respiratory secretions that
are hard to clear from the air would
allow bacteria to become more easily
trapped and causing infection and
inflammation in the world although in
the pancreas that organ that helps you
break down all the fat protein carbs and
fat me when you just on the disease
blocks these enzymes that prohibits
digestion
this means that necessary fat soluble
for vitamins don't get absorbed into the
bloodstream okay ten plates
nicely missing necessary service so the
medicines follow the synthetic enzymes
vitamins antibiotics to you know stop
infection mucus spinners and
bronchodilators to facilitate greeted
sufferers of cystic fibrosis digests
less they have to eat more more calories
than dwarfs that all while maintaining a
healthy weight because a healthy body
makes for strong immune system and in
this case have some herb over to
exercise like this is a must so let's so
how's that is there life different from
how well they have to take different
medicines all day long they have to use
a nebulizer to inhale special mist
medicines directly into their lungs they
have to watch their sugar because
diabetes is especially prevalent among
the cystic fibrosis community they're
getting out of the hospital they can't
smoke cigarettes or marijuana because
they're especially susceptible to fungi
and bacteria they can't drink alcohol
but only in moderation though that might
be said for everybody ah she's stretched
should have stretched should have
stretch should stretch
let it doesn't for
let it be known that just in Surrey I
know the cameraman also made it up 50
plates with me thank you very much Jay
thanks so do you remember the CFTR gene
well here's what's happening on a
molecular level
gene is like a little instruction manual
tells amino acids how to shape
themselves into proteins are these
wildly complex shapes like bunches of
ribbon that perform various functions in
the bio the shape is everything it's a
name and a job all in one it tells
everything around what it's there to do
the CFTR protein coming from the CFTR
gene sits on the membrane of cells and
facilitates the coming and going of
sodium chloride or salt okay good so far
the mutation associated with cystic
fibrosis is a faulty instruction the
protein is constructed wrong and instead
of facilitating the patterns of salt it
blocks it and this is what creates the
mucus buildup and all the other troubles
now there's a drug in development by
vertex pharmaceuticals called the x-77
it's a CFTR potentiate ER and it aims to
increase the function of those defective
CFTR genes by increasing the gating
activity or the ability for ions to be
transported across the cell membrane
phase 3 of FDA trials and it has had
promising results so far along partly
due to the fund-raising done by the
Cystic Fibrosis Foundation or the CF F
and we can only hope for the best this
is why raising understanding is better
than raising awareness because you know
where your money is dumped you donate to
this cause you're donating to the
research and development of gene therapy
treatments that will attack this disease
and its root and potentially cure those
affected with cystic fibrosis forever we
all get just one life and then we die
and that's the end all we can hope for
is to get 60 or 80 or a hundred years of
it to do what we love to spend it with
family and friends to create to learn to
do whatever we feel is donate and give
those with cystic fibrosis the chance of
a hundred years is why raising money is
better than raising understanding and
it's what they all did and it's what he
did
which I guess makes me the pussy you
could find information
donated the doobly-doo blog 13